guy millière bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin dans la matinale de rtl
france alors c'est du jamais vu personne
ne s'attendait finalement à ce scénario
quelle est votre réaction ce matin à les
réactions autour de vous à las vegas
déjà je commencerai par dire qu' aucun
conservateur aucun républicain n'a
troubles ce qui s'est passé tous les
républicains tous les conservateurs
dénoncent la violence et donald trump le
premier donald trump n'a jamais appelé à
la violence et il reste à expliciter ce
qui s'est effectivement passé ce n'est
pas obligatoirement très clair des gens
disent que des antilles fin ont incité à
la violence et donc je dirais qu'il
n'apportera que la justice passe ainsi
quand et quelques ce pas cette chance là
deuxième point par rapport à ce qui
s'est dit et je pense qu'il est très
important de souligner la moitié au
moins de la population américaine c'est
ce que montre tous les sondages pensent
que les élections du 3 novembre ont été
des élections volées est que les fraudes
ont été massives il ya beaucoup de
documents qui montrent que ces pros
d'exister et donc donald trump quand ils
protestent les résultats toutes les
raisons de les contester on est dans un
contexte où la justice est défaillante
ont dit que des juges en ont rejeté les
plaintes déposées par les avocats des
deux bâle iii
c'est inexact et refuser d'examiner les
preuves qu'on leur présentait ils vont
dire on ne veut pas toucher à cette
chose-là la coupe tu prendre ces
conduites exactement de la même façon et
je dirais que dans un état de droit pour
la justice ne peut pas passer par les
juges ne se dépense
et bien il y a une population qui peut
être très laid ce prêt mais je dirais
que la population frustrée qui est en
bonne partie de la population américaine
ne recourent pas en général à la
violence les républicains ne sont pas
des gens violents menés violence on les
a vus lorsque antifa et black la gloire
contagion et les violences sont plutôt
des choses qui viennent de l'extrême
gauche
ceci étant dit le contexte vous êtes à
venir une formule est extrêmement
malsain quand vous êtes dans un contexte
où la moitié de la population pense que
l'élection était odieuse
et qu'elle a été volée vous êtes dans un
contexte où la démocratie fonctionne
extrêmement balle j'ai publié en anglais
il ya deux jours un article pour get
stoned qui dit que la démocratie
américaine est profondément détraqué et
je pense que c'est le cas et c'est très
inquiétant la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes et je dirais que si jo
baydan arrivants pouvoir de circonstance
sur la planète connaît déjà dit je dois
répéter un président qui sera
profondément illégitime et je dirais que
donald trump a toutes les raisons de
contester ces élections je dirais que je
tiens mis le feu aux poudres endormi
c'est le discours qu'a tenu mike pence
mike pence aurait pu dire c'est ce qui
était prévu a priori je renvoie le les
listes de grands acteurs contestait vers
les législatures des six états où les
décisions de nomination des grands
électeurs sont contestés pas soit ce que
les législatures agissent et je dirais
que la constitution américaine vit
d'ailleurs qu'elle ce sont les
législatures qui doivent désigner les
grands électeurs du tout le gouverneur
de l'état secrétaire d'état de l'état et
donc mike pence n'a pas fait cela et je
dirais que ça va contribuer à énerver la
frustrer beaucoup de gens y compris moi
même d'ailleurs je ne m'attendais pas à
ce que mike pence ou conduisent comme
cela et je dirais que mike pence a déçu
beaucoup de gens qui est jack sa
carrière politique et cachot veine avec
ce qu'il vient de faire
mais je dirais que même m difficile pour
lui de sortir dans la rue sans se faire
insulter dans la suite des semaines
qu'ils montent effectivement on va
attendre qu'une enquête soit menée
puisque ce sera le cas vraisemblablement
vu l'ampleur des événements qui se sont
passés hier au capitole c'est le symbole
de la démocratie américaine où vous
l'avez dit les condamnations sont
unanimes guy millière néanmoins vous
pensez que cette scission de la société
américaine on n'a pas vu venir cette
colère extrême d'une partie de la
population américaine mène la population
américaine c'est ce que j'explique dans
mon dernier livre qui s'appelle un
prêtre un point d'interrogation
c'est une population qui est
actuellement très très divisée c'est une
population dans laquelle vous avez des
gens qui appartiennent à l'amérique
ultra
10 ionel qui se reconnaissent dans
toutes les valeurs américaines et puis
des gens qui ont été chauffés à blanc
par le fait que le parti démocrate est
un parti qui a glissé très très
nettement à gauche ces dernières années
ce n'est plus le parti de john kennedy
je n'ai plus parlé de bill clinton
c'est un parti dans lequel vous avez des
gens qui sont très radicaux des gens qui
sont socialistes des jonctions marxiste
ce n'est pas une habitude aux états unis
et verser des gens comme cela et je
dirais que depuis quatre ans l'un des
chapitres dont l'une s'appelle
d'ailleurs coups d'état depuis quatre
ans
vous avez une tentative de
déstabilisation constante de donald
trump des appels à la violence d'élus
démocrates et je dirais que nos climats
et des tempêtes malchance depuis depuis
quatre ans mais cette année ça s'est
exacerbée il ya eu une tentative de du
pitch m contre donald trump qui ne
reposait sur strictement rien et on l'a
vu très rapidement il y à une
utilisation du pour un virus et il ya
encore beaucoup d'états démocrate où
tous les commerces sont quasiment tous
les commerces sont fermés où le chômage
a monté en flèche
il ya eu ensuite les émeutes provoquées
par anti char et black d'amateurs qui
ont fait d'énormes destructions et on
n'en parle pas mais il n'ya plus de 25
mois aurait compris des enfants qui ont
été tués pendant les cours de ces
émeutes ya 500 policiers qui ont été
blessés pour certains gravement il ya
des milliards de dégâts qui ont été
provoqués
la population a subi tout cela et en
supplément de cela au bout du compte il
ya une élection qui est une élection
véritablement frauduleux directe
comptant pas l'histoire de cette
élection on verra que les fraudes ont
été massives et que l'élection a été
volée à tonale trapèze et déjà que ça ne
devait pas se passer de cette passion là
et je dirais que je suis très inquiet
pour le futur des états unis dans le
contexte actuel je ne pense pas que le
calme ne pourra revenir très très
facilement
ce n'est pas sain dans une démocratie
pour la justice n'est pas de la place et
quand les élections ne sont pas
légitimes
alors je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction de joe biden il a été l'un des
premiers à réagir pendant que les
partisans de donald trump était dans le
capital il a qualifié ces violences je
cite d'insurrection notre démocratie vit
une agression sans précédent at il
déclaré avant de demander à donald trump
de se rendre devant les caméras pour
demander à ses partisans de quitter le
capitole le président élu qui a
également demandé à donald trump de
respecter son serment à la constitution
écouter une attaque contre l'état de
droit comme on en a rarement vu une
attaque contre la plus sacrée des
entreprises américaines la conduite des
affaires du peuple
permettez-moi d'être très clair les
scènes de chaos au capitole ne reflète
pas l'amérique véritable ne représente
pas ce que nous sommes
cette journée nous rappelle de manière
douloureuse que la démocratie est
fragile et que sa préservation nécessite
des personnes de bonne volonté des
dirigeants qui ont le courage de se
lever qui sont dévouées non pas la
poursuite du pouvoir ou de leurs
intérêts personnels est la poursuite de
leur propre intérêt égoïste à tout prix
mais au bien commun
on entendu à une insurrection pour eux
joe biden plusieurs élus ont également
compté condamné une tentative de coup
d'état selon vous est-ce que c'est ce
qu'a vécu les états unis hier une
tentative de coup d'état
à mes yeux une tentative de coup d'état
c'est ce que je suis dans mon livre
après tron que qui a commencé depuis
novembre deux chaises et la tentative de
coup d'état est la venue des démocrates
j'ai résumé un petit peu tout ce qu'ils
ont fait depuis quatre ans et je dirais
que ce discours de john dryden relève de
l'imposture d'une part parce que donald
trump a immédiatement appelé à la
violence
ap les halles à ce que les troubles 16
concrètement et demandé à tous ceux qui
le soutiennent de rentrer chez eux dans
ces conditions il n'a jamais appelé à la
violence et il n'a pas cessé de dire
qu'il était le gardien de la
constitution il s'est révélé fidèle à la
constitution 10 cas aujourd'hui et je
dirais que le discours de joe biden ne
relève à mes yeux de vous
suis désolé de le dire on est de
l'imposture parce que si quelqu'un
chauffer quelque chose à l'état de droit
tous les gens qui ont organisé cette
fraude massive et je dirais que si les
démocrates avaient vraiment voulu que le
calme soit là dès le 4 novembre dès
qu'il est avéré qu'il y avait des
preuves massive il serait dû contribuer
avec les républicains parce que les
froids ne soient démontées à ce qu'elle
soit mise au jour est ce que tout soit
clarifié tous cas rentrait dans l'ordre
des élections il n'y a pas de fraude
sont des vers et des élections que tout
le monde approuve donc pour ce qui me
concerne si j'avais vu que je ne joue
pas et n avait gagné de manière légale
comme cela dit je regrette mais bon
c'est la laisser la démocratie
mais ce n'est pas ce qui s'est passé il
y a des rapports entier dont on ne
parlait à ce que très très peu ou pas du
tout en france qui montre l'ampleur des
trop d'équipement le détail de ces
fraudes et je dirais que comme je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure si la justice était
passé si des juges avaient regardé ces
éléments s'il les avait pris en compte
nous ne serions pas là aujourd'hui
la justice a fait défaut la justice a
démissionné
et donc quand la justice démissionne et
bien il ya des frustrations je suis lié
à des troubles
il y a des graves problèmes qui se
dessine et nous sommes
aucun de ces gradins problème comme je
lui ai dit la dernière fois que
l'occupation sur arte france où il n'y
aura pas de possibilité pour joe biden
d'être inauguré deux prêté serment
devant le capitole devant une foule
immense qui aura pas de foule
il va se rendre à la maison blanche
comme peut s'y rendre quelqu'un qui n'a
pas de légitimité parce qu'il n'a pas de
légitimité
merci beaucoup c'est votre point de vue
des miliaires merci de l'avoir partagé
avec nous sur ce plateau
ce matin on verra effectivement si le
temps vous donne raison pour
l'investiture de joe biden le 20 janvier
prochain